una campaña más grande del mundo
empiezan unas 600 millones de personas
en india son aptas para recibir una
vacuna contra el cob y 19 pero el
proceso de inoculación ha tenido un
lento inicio estamos completamente
preparados nuestros trabajadores
sanitarios están listos para la campaña
pero no tenemos vacunas del niño india
produce dosis desarrolladas por
astrazéneca y su propia vacuna kóvacs in
pero varios estados han advertido que no
tienen suficientes inyecciones el
gobierno indio ha dicho que ha invertido
masivamente para acelerar la producción
pero con un promedio de 75 millones de
dosis producidas cada mes tomaría años
inocular a toda la población adulta unas
940 millones de personas las compañías
farmacéuticas acusan a eeuu de acaparar
el suministro de materias primas
enfrentando una escasez aguda los
centros de vacunación han estado
cerrados alrededor del país
le estamos pidiendo a la gente de
karnataka especialmente a quienes tienen
entre 18 y 44 años que se abstengan de
ir a hospitales pensando que serán
vacunados todos hostels
pinging de brax en el dedo esto se
presenta mientras india lucha en el peor
momento del brote docenas de países han
ofrecido ayuda enviando cilindros de
oxígeno y otros suministros médicos para
los hospitales abarrotados pero en medio
de una ola de solidaridad otros
gobiernos también han restringido los
viajes a india eeuu ha anunciado que a
los extranjeros que lleguen de india no
se les permitirá la entrada mientras que
australia suspendió todos los vuelos
advirtiendo que los ciudadanos que no
cumplan podrían enfrentar una sentencia
de cinco años de cárcel